c'est vraiment traitement à l'eau ouais
je connaisse c'est père est un [ __ ]
monsieur par tous téo je viens pas
d'accord je veux dire si tu veux j'ai
pas de problème a dit au site la femme
vient péri dommage
ah oui
faye est évidemment jallet jallet fait
de laisser venir au casse-pipe tout seul
mais bon il s'en sort pas trop mal tout
les gens sont marais à savoir sympa non
ah ouais tu vois je pense que nourriture
de vivre non mais c'est une connerie le
bouquet n'existe pas c'est très sympa
non mais je vous le conseille pour une
seule raison c'est que ça va rentrer du
pognon la maison ça c'est déjà une
raisonnable n'était pas pour celle-là
c'est que papa fini de le lire et que tu
vois une mouche passé dans ta chambre un
truc comme ça tu dis c'est peut-être
quelqu'un que je connais qui en train de
mater en train de regarder ce que je
fais dans mon lit c'est un peu dommage
que tu étais là parce qu'il y avait un
truc entre mélanie et guillaume là je
peux repartir si tu veux c'est ce que je
vais vous faire un but que je vous ai
tous les deux une interview alerte aux
roses terry est ce que tu as besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de faire
l'amour pour aimer moi je dirais les
deux ça dépend des jours à l'aller on a
tué 1
et toi moi ça dépend de la fille c'est
quoi ta première pensée péri quand tu te
trouve en face d'un mec séduisant je me
demande si dit la vérité la vérité c'est
est ce que je peux lui plairait ce que
ça peut aller plus loin est ce que je
sais pas non franchement je veux que tu
vois et même séduisant c'est ça chaque
fois que je te vois en tout cas tu
chantes pas comme des trucs qui te
pousse la menora m'a renvoyé vers l'est
c'est quoi le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte pourquoi ce que les italiens
c'est la machine à laver vous savez ça
mais sur les orages
ouais tu resteras se fait sous rage
c'est quoi mais pas à l'intérieur un
guillaume le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte pour toi juste au pied du lit 1
avant de monter à vendre cher à d'autres
questions dont j'ai bon guillaume est ce
que tu préfères une femme qui pèse bien
mais qui est infidèle ou une femme qui
baisent mal mais qu'est fidèles femme
qui laisse bien fidèles à m
ah oui est ce que tu préfères draguer
draguer ça dépend qui gère face de moi
mais j'aime bien me faire draguer du
drac des fois oui oui je les draguer tu
préfèrerais qu'elles te quitte pour une
femme pour un homme pour un homme sont
soit plus marrant ah ouais moi aussi je
faire et on quitte pour un homme
ouais c'est vrai est ce que tu préfères
être caressé par quelqu'un qui très puiu
battu par quelqu'un qui t'aiment ans
battu par quelqu'un qui m'aime
est ce que tu préfères que perry couche
avec un autre en pensant à toi ou couche
avec toi on pense en un autre cas une
couche avec moi en pensant un autre moi
c'est pas mal ça qu'elle couche avec toi
mais à oui mais monsieur janssen 51 ans
thierry cammal
ouais tu vois je préfère me coucher avec
toi en pensant à une autre vie vous
savez que notre bon sens à toi qui
couche avec moi en pensant à moi ah
c'est pas possible c'est trop tard est
ce que bon ça fait 20 ans que cet
ensemble est ce que c'est encore un
fantasmes inavouables et non réalisés
inavoués non j'en vienne souffre et on
s'est tous dit surtout est ce que
l'amour est compatible avec le mariage
permis à perry pardon ah oui on assiste
ici complètement la presse
la preuve la preuve vivante depuis 20
ans je les adore et j'espère que les
récits et les mariés de la 2 depuis 20
ans vous êtes pas trompés jamais trompé
n'ont trompé non parce que celui-ci
s'est trompé ça dépend ce que tu sais la
réponse que tu suces perry est ce que
sucer c'est tromper si tu mens oui pour
moi tromper c'est mentir
tu ressembles un oui c'est vrai c'est
non si tu ne ment pas t'as pas trompé
donc voilà après donc sucer s'est pas
trompé son lit
donc tu vois je vais bosser jaloux et
j'ai cité le poids
tu penses quand on avoue finalement non
pas quand on avoue quand on dit ouais
c'est pas à vous et à vous et ce à des
fellations avoué de métier connue mais
oui non mais avouez c'est à dire que tu
as menti et que tu te leurs proches et
qu'ensuite tu te dis tiens je vais
l'avouer je vais le dire là c'est pas du
tout ça donc simuler ses troupes et
ouais ah oui je suis arrivé s'est trompé
on apprend des trucs assez de service
public à l'objet d'apprendre des choses
un petit peu gens est-ce que vous
éteignez ou allumer la lumière quand
vous baisez chez vous non franchement
non il n'y a pas de règle je ne suis pas
t'attendrai du toi tu non non j'ai la
drague les basques p 82 n'y a pas de
règle
c'est quoi la zone la plus érogène chez
toi perry bas jatte
merci il a dit pour moi
kerry avec quelques personnes ici
présentes tu aimerais avoir une aventure
soit honnête imagine conçoit dans un
monde idéal où ça pose pas de problème
on a connu ça dans les années 70 mais
bon maintenant c'est fini c'est un truc
à plusieurs mais pas en dessous parce
qu'il fait 130 kg
alors voir si guillaume et honnête avec
qui tu voudrais avoir une aventure là à
moi ma voisine il est génial c'est de la
merde
suspense il te la neige voilà je peux à
miss france
est ce que tu préfères une femme belle
et conne ou une femme moche et
intelligente mais vous l'avez à l'école
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu préfères une femme
comprend sans la comprendre qu'on
comprend sans la france qu'on comprend
sans la prendre
ah ouais ouais t'as compris des capable
de ça tu vois qu'on comprend sans la
prendre je préfère une femme qu'on
comprend et comprend pas si je pouvais
posséder que la moitié de perry tu
prendrais le bas ou le haut dans le bas
le bas pourquoi là bas parce que y'a et
tu vois si vous voulez prendre que la
moitié de guillaume tu pourrais le bas
ou le haut non moi je prends l'eau parce
que tout est dans la tête de tous les
jours mais si justement à tout est dans
la tête parce que même si on reparlait
de fantasmes sexualité etc
c'est aussi dans la tête n'est pas ce
que j'ai bien du coteau bout du crew que
on s'est rencontrés par le haut par le
voilà merci
dernière question vous baiser avant le
restaurant où après le restaurant au
restaurant tableau ça peut être au
restaurant oui plus souvent après
vraiment plus souvent après qu'avant
chaque fois que ces deux restaurants
avant restait en tous les soirs pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu